there's so much hype surrounding this
movie what is it like for you guys the
actors director producer bringing these
characters to the big screen and
balancing what comic book fans already
know and what you guys wanted to bring
to the characters I think Jared should
go first and she had the hardest job on
the whole movie for me it was it was
actually the role of a lifetime I had so
much fun playing the Joker I could
easily just play the Joker a couple more
times and retire it was a buzz but you
guys seemed like you were having all the
fun on the movie yeah no we we were we
were really enjoying it David Ayer has a
very interesting process of getting
actors into their characters we
manipulation yes yes manipulation
domination torture yeah so we all got in
a room and he had you know essentially
is much more like therapy than that it
was you know your character creation so
we sat and we talked about our lives and
you know we we got really close as we
you know our triumphs and tribulations
and trials and and then at the most
opportune moment Joel describes it best
that he would completely betray us and
betray that trust and he would get a
very unique reaction secrets aren't
getting disclosed it's a process it's
like a you know gymnasium for acting as
well
and it just kind of you know and you do
these guys to feel like your best
friends on camera and you know when
you're with your best friend you share
secrets you talk about your inner life
there's a way you talk to a really close
friend and and I wanted them to have
that energy in the fastest way to get
there was to have them beat the hell out
of each other share their secrets and
otherwise yeah oh that's so sad you
started training we'd be fighting
hurting each other and next thing you
know David must show up Adam what what
you were doing I do not want to
categorize that as training the best
Nevada was doing body squats bodyweight
squats like what I want to say David was
a champion show up train with us beat us
up there was this moment he was sparring
with Karen and she got in the nose back
her guard was open lunch me in the face
he said you got to block your face
this man made me push so many weights
and get big and when I got to the size
that he desired for Killer Croc and I
figured I was ready you said now you got
to fight Karen you know and and you look
at the size of her but got to call you
that she beat to beat the crap out of
prop I mean I could go all out because
Otto Wally's so big and strong so much
you can just well clearly you guys all
really bonded on the set and I know that
our press have some great questions for
you guys as well so let's take our first
one from right over there what's your
name bro what's your question for Margot
will and Jarek what was the most
challenging aspect of making this movie
and was anybody mildly injured during
any of the physical scenes or any
mishaps during the physical uh my mild
injuries mild yeah you when you're when
you're 47 no injury is a mild injury
anymore oh yeah I tore my calf a couple
of weeks and and it was and it was
terrible is you you do it doing nothing
like I wasn't doing anything we you know
we're sparring and I stepped back to
throw a shot and my calf pop and you
know you can you can hear it people
could hear it and everybody was like oh
there's that that's that's that's not
good
whatever that sound what is not a good
sound and then he said the doctor told
me I was down for six weeks so on a
movie like this you know six weeks
clicks up or can click off at you know
significant amounts of money that I
wasn't going to pay for it you know but
it was um it was really scary to to be
in that position I was like oh my god
this opportunity Suicide Squad having
this chance and maybe not going to be
able to to deliver the way I wanted to
but it will soldier on and then I think
three seconds later Joel blew out his
cap yes okay
just you know I was just trying to show
sympathy everything yeah it was like a
sympathy pregnancy solitary injury I
don't where you gotta say pregnancy
oh yeah it's a weird sorry mr. move on
yeah we should just keep going Marga
what was the hardest part for you like
other than doing everything we had to do
except you did it in heels yeah that was
tricky um and I had less layers to hide
padding and stuff doing stunts so that
made it a little painful any I only got
I think we I thought I broke my rib at
one point but I actually just I actually
tore the muscles off the rib instead of
bring it but it was fine it was towards
the Atlantic coming off the troll my god
you're hurt so much
it'll the tape there's like 50 extras
there's pyrotechnics he's got up these
raw like palms blue like this high up
right onto my knees on the bitumen no is
so painful that I don't she stands alone
I'm fine yeah cry in front of all those
people I'm kind of good I fell off a
stage the other day in Toronto as well
again just pumped up I was like that
didn't hurt yeah but the hardest part
wasn't the physical side actually that
was all but you know that's a mechanical
science challenging but it's rewarding
and fun and um the emotional stuff was
definitely more difficult exposing my
most vulnerable sides in front of a room
full of strangers at that point that
that was incredibly hard um trying to
figure out the dynamic between Harley
and Joker and why she is so devoted to
this guy that tries to kill her
occasionally I mean it's like a few
things like that it took a while to get
my head around but the physical side was
was just more fun and challenging you
guys keep bringing up the fact that you
know you did share so much stuff with
each other which was harder for you to
keep the film secrets a secret or to
keep the stuff that you guys shared with
each other a secret Jon Kitna doesn't
yeah there is no secret all my jewels
here
soldier soldier soldier yes Joel
Kinnaman tell us everything is great
awesome so you guys are pretty
tight-lipped with that answer you like
just ask Joel everything else is secret
yeah umm who is our next question from
right in the front hi can you talk a
little bit about bringing humanity and
humor into all the mayhem for this David
was really great because for from the
beginning it was clear he wanted to do
something different he wanted to do
something special he wanted to make
something that was something we'd all be
really proud of and I could get the
sense from him that he was willing to go
to all lengths in order to get that and
that was both a little scary but also
really exciting and he's not only the
director but the writer of the film and
I was surprised by how much freedom he
gave I think everybody to just go
completely [ __ ] crazy
God and he was God but but but what I
thought was really genius about David is
he was always looking for the accident
he was always looking for the mistake
and embracing that and and and for Margo
and I there was a lot of humor there was
a lot of things that I thought were
really funny in a very sick and twisted
way but uh he was really wonderful
in that way thank you David thank you
yes thank you when when David and I
first had a discussion you know and he
presented Killer Croc with the
prosthetics that were very extensive my
first question to him is is anybody
actually gonna know I'm in there and he
said absolutely because he really wanted
an actor that could bring the soul of
the creatures to life and I think with
all of us
these are villains with souls and I
think that's indicative of his vision
and as a beautiful moment in the movie
where Killer Croc was very easy to have
a punchline that is ugly but you know he
says I'm beautiful and it sends a
statement when a crocodilian reptilian
black man can say I'm beautiful about
acceptance you know and I think in this
kind of genre that's very fearless and
quite bold to make humane statements so
but he wasn't humane and second when you
go to his trailer it was all about
cannibalism he's he's listening to
cannibal chance on his phone so you go
chairman you go Hayati and he's like oh
yeah now he took it he took it very
serious like he was watching a crocodile
videos of you know things and you know
cannibalism and all that and I think
that as a cast we have a question and I
think auto wale should answer this
question honestly once and for all once
you did you use any of your assistance
because there was an assistant
came up missing there was we had an
assistant and it was that what was the
guy's name the young guys and you just
just wants it for all week we all think
you ate him so we just we need to know
yeah we were I got a surprise for you
he's in your trailer wrapped in a bow
with a big smile no no no but yeah the
right we all I think we all took us here
I kept it very serious the guy that
would kind of keep us together and for
from my point of view I saw joy as our
go-to guide to liven it up because
boomerang had this weird kind of like
nature right from getting out of his his
bag sack bag but he he really was I
thought the guy that really brought that
crazy cuz he'd have to turn it up a
notch definitely brought the crazy I've
got I've done love scenes in movies I
had quite a few movies where I've had
really extensive love scenes but I've
never had a co started I've seen naked
more than Josh you know it was like he
just he had a really really hard time
keeping his clothes auto sure he didn't
feel a need he just didn't feel there
isn't anything see something interesting
when I was on this set I saw a
photograph of a naked man yes running
after David Ayer yes who had a look of
abject terror
yeah cause fear and have perfect running
for everybody at the Olympics I mean the
most aerodynamic warm in a look of its
concentration as he did I think it
wasn't naked Jamie my gosh you know we
can't say for certain hard as you like
so the story behind that picture
a person that kind of said Sikkim true
story behind it is I'll show you
everything it's not much more to it
David used to like to come in and visit
kind of the like base camp where our
trailers were all would be well
Andrew nothing was on fire yeah every
now and then he'd come and keep an eye
on things and pretty but he would just
open the trailer door and he'd be in the
kind of in there like what's up dude and
this is one time I was like I was
getting out of the shower and I came in
and I opened the doors saw up dude I was
like oh what's up and I just you know it
was the opportune moment so I dropped
the towel and went after sick and boy an
OPS they went around whole parking lot
it was a I never got him can we start
like an online poll or like a charity
drive to release this photo I'd be like
you know like good sheriff yeah yeah
that's true all right yeah let's talk
about it's up to David all right who has
our next question back I uh my name is
siti I write for black hole nerds and hi
everybody and this is a question for the
woman viola bar go Kara Karen uh one of
the things that actors have to do is
they have to find a way to connect with
their character so probably create a
backstory for them even though this is
based on a comic book so there's our in
your backstory but what are some ways
that you kind of tapped into play your
characters and is there a way that you
can identify play these female
characters but not at so as badass or
smart or strong go baby boom
a bowl and narcissistic or anything of
that sort
um I mean I did a lot of research the
thing I found really helpful for just
filling in the gaps because like you
said we had an amazing resource at with
the comic books and but there are still
little gaps in the backstory and things
you need to fill in yourself and um I
watched a couple of TED talks on
schizophrenia and amongst like a bunch
of other things but that really helped
because the women that were doing these
talks were so intelligent I mean there
were professors they were you know and
Holly needs to be wickedly intelligent
but also kind of psychotic so um I don't
know I found that I found that and you
told me I think you told me to go look
at the TED talk but it was so helpful um
and I also got recommended to read a
play called Paul for love about this
really dysfunctional relationship and
that for whatever reason will help me
unlock the whole you know feeling
towards some the Joker so yeah it was
like it was things that I don't know you
some things hit home when you're doing
all your research and some things kind
of don't but it's yeah that really
helped
I definitely wonder how you connected
with that character well Joel gave me a
book Joel gave me a book called
confessions of a sociopath and I read
that book extensively and one of the
things it's it's it's the confessions of
a woman who's a sociopath and one of the
things I found out is a lot of CEOs of
companies are sociopaths people who have
no guilt if they cry their only crime
because they feel like they're losing
control and I also I tapped into viola
at eight because I can't tap in the
viola at 51 at eight
I could beat somebody's ass and I could
beat somebody's ass I was just always
angry because you know people were
always teasing me I was bullied and I
remember that was the first story I told
Dave David when I met him he was like oh
yeah if I'll just tell me about your
childhood I said well David I remember
when I was eight years old I kicked a
lot of ass and I'd so there was a part
of me they had to tap into that because
as with women with me I'm always
apologizing I'm shy
I'm always retreating I never tap into
my power and Amanda Waller is not that
she is on apologetically brutal and I
yeah you know cuz I had to call him a
[ __ ] a couple of times but I had to tap
into that because otherwise I would have
retreated and with this group I couldn't
retreat so that's what I did now she did
not retreat at all there was no retreat
it was pretty much everyday that me and
Biola had together on said she would you
know with David would call on her to
like come and stand behind the camera
and then she'd stand behind the camera
and just yell mean things at me she'd be
like hey Joel Joel flag you little [ __ ]
punk-ass [ __ ] yes'm okay good morning
good morning that was that that was my
experience like he liked it likes he
likes um Amanda Waller yeah yeah she was
got it happens and film a lot is is the
male voices and by voice I mean the
character the depth of the character the
performance the way the character is
resolved in executed the arc of the
character is incredibly developed and
often the women are underdeveloped in
this case I wanted women that had voices
and had power and we're powerful as
women and you know as a father of two
daughters I think it's important to give
them examples that you can speak up in
the world and you can have a viewpoint
don't let him see that sorry
what about Bert Karen and Cara you go
gang
oh you go girl honey right here bro um
go cat for her question yeah well coming
from a japanese-american family we had a
lot of those cultures and values
Japanese cultures and values growing up
in the household you know with my first
language and we grew up on Japanese
traditions and food and TV and all of
that
so I think when I when I first read the
katana comics
I immediately fell in love and I
immediately felt like felt like there
was a part of her inside of me even
though our personalities were so
completely different and for me the the
the switch really happened when I put on
the mask and the Wardrobe and that
really helped me tap into the character
okay so for me um some of the first
things David said to me were about
looking into things like addiction
trying to find like you know never like
never getting enough or never feeling
like anything is enough and constantly
needing something and that kind of thing
and then also it was trying to find the
kind of opposites of her and also kind
of trying to find a demon inside myself
which I definitely was able to find and
exercise yeah that wasn't our just quite
easy yeah yeah yeah just right
it's right that right that wasn't too
hard so I had an easy job um and kind of
trying to make that as real as possible
and understand why someone would do
something that evil or want to really
heart that many people and and just
trying to make it real
I guess cuz I think that that's what
David wanted for this movie
that's what he gave us a that's what I
wanted to give I think we've got one
more question in the audience oh right
over here hi this question is for David
so this is one of the most diverse cast
we've seen in a really long time and so
which i think is like amazing right but
um that's just my personal opinion but
um so when you were writing the film
when you were writing it it's just
something you were thinking about or did
it just happen like organically like
were you like looking and you were
saying viola's Amanda Waller which hell
yes but um you know were you thinking
about any of that
I mean look for me you know I grew up in
South LA I grew up in early diverse
neighborhood I was the only white boy
that's how diverse it was I mean and
yeah it's a you know it's the world I
know it's what I live in but it's also
the world we all live in and I feel like
on on-screen
you know kids need to see people that
look like them you know my wife is
latina you know my kids are Latino so
it's important for them to see faces
like there's on the screen and and this
is also it's a global business these
days and we need to evolve all the times
but you know it it comes naturally to me
but I think you know that's in diversity
is strength and we need to be a lot more
inclusive and film we really need to
work on that and in our world in general
I love hearing what everybody had to say
and thank you guys so much for your
questions but I want to know to just
seeing all of the cast up here and
hearing how you guys interact together
for Charles and David and Richard did
you guys ever have moments on set where
you were like oh my god what did we get
ourselves into how is this movie getting
me
that way at all it was like I mean look
at this
cast assembled up here in this great
filmmaker it's a producer's dream it's
the best way I could equate is like
being the manager of the all-star team
you get to go to work every day and you
get to see the greatest actors in the
world all collaborating together so for
me it was a producer's dream because you
really are watching the best of the best
go to work and I couldn't ask for a
better job and I would just echo that by
also saying you know David took these
great characters from the you know the
can in the comics and he wrote a great
script that had great characterizations
and and then we had this amazing group
of actors actually really mine it and
make it even better so it was really a
producer's dream not all the time in
terms of getting them to get serious
sometimes but at the end at the end of
the day and watching the dailies it
couldn't have been better working on
films if the guys on top aren't on our
level as the actors it's not going to
work so to know that our leaders out
there were we're setting up and making
it that comfortable space we wouldn't be
who we are so you know they're blowing
it off to like it's like anyways and it
comes from the top you know so you're
saying they were running around naked
right next yeah yeah yes Chuck all the
time Chuck all the time the trick is is
never show fear that there are many I am
one you can never show fear turn on you
you know and the other thing is always
have an answer even if you're just
making it up nobody's saying just just
pretend you know what you're doing and
they kind of will follow you ya know
every once in a while we would look at
David and I'm like hey man you know you
just made that up
right
you know that's not the real answer to
the question you just made it up he was
really good he called me out you'd be
like okay is that like ready yeah